I certainly don't think that's a good
use of our resources it's certainly not
a good use of our time on this floor
here's representative prila gal she's in
the Hamas caucus and uh rather than
being concerned about the amount of
illegals coming here and the crime that
we're seeing on our streets and they're
kicking homeless people out of shelters
and the fenel and all that she's very
upset that we keep calling these people
illegals we really saying that we think
the best use of our very limited federal
government resources is to work on
deporting a green card holder who
decided to sleep in their car rather
than drive home drunk from a bar a green
card holder not trying to drive drunk
just trying to stay warm I certainly
don't think that's a good use of our
resources it's certainly not a good use
of our time on this floor but my
colleagues on the other side of the
aisle have made it clear that they're
not interested in sensible Solutions
just in
sensationalism this bill is another
example of that and I hope my colleagues
will stop referring to people as
illegals people are human beings they
have different statuses some are
undocumented if you want to say some are
illegal but let's not call human beings
illegal tired of that language I urge my
colleagues to reject this bill and I
yield back the balance of they are
illegal and I have some language that I
can't say about you but I'm going to
write on this piece of paper and I'm
going to send it to someone in locals
you know what I wrote It's that word
that's what I wrote here and I'm going
to sign it Dave ruin and we're going to
send it to somebody on locals um did you
also catch the fact that she wants she's
encouraging people with green cards to
drive drunk on top of everything else
these people are absolutely
extraordinary they are illegal they
should not be here we can talk about
Pathway to citizenship we got to close
the border but the Democrats are here to
destroy the
country